[Musique]
la crise est de la guerre d'Ukraine
ça nous affecte mais ça vient déjà de
avant d'acheter l'huile
il y a un an à 80 cents le litre et
en ce moment c'est actuellement 260 le
litres est une augmentation de plus de 300 %.
Mais ça a été la vente aux enchères, c'était déjà là
monter tout beaucoup et il n'y avait pas
soulevé la farine nous avions soulevé le
pétrole mais ça a déjà été ça c'est
rendre l'entreprise non rentable
[Musique]
Eh bien, je pense que les gens sont
transporter toute l'huile de tournesol pour
peur que ce type n'arrive pas en Espagne
d'huile mais il me semble que c'est un
la peur qu'on avait auparavant quand
la bande dessinée avec du papier toilette
[Musique]
ce qui peut nous manquer de tournesol et
ci-après et le
situation critique, nous devrions penser
dans d'autres alternatives Pour occuper cela
espace pour les bouteilles de
l'huile de tournesol Et c'est le premier
solution en Espagne pour quoi
nous sommes le premier producteur mondial de
l'huile d'olive c'est de l'huile d'olive
[Musique]
Nous avons fait des tests avec
tout ce qu'on a pu trouver dans
marché Il est vrai qu'en Espagne
ce que nous avons le plus et ce que nous nommons le plus
nous donne est l'huile d'olive et
la réalité est que bien qu'il serve à
beaucoup de choses pour la friture et pour et pour
les autres préparations de pâtisserie ne
vaut pour le goût que vous avez un goût
qui a tellement d'acidité et qui est tellement agressif
[Musique]